みなさん、こんにちは。このエピソードでは
、ドゴンによる日本の音声学の第4話へようこそ。
このエピソードでは、
音声認識といくつかの
重要な音声学の
実践について説明します。
ネイティブのようなアクセントを開発するには、
一時的に文法と
漢字の勉強を制限し、
代わりにこの時間を音声学に割り当てると便利です。
音声学を勉強していない人は悪い音声学の習慣につながるため、
悪い音声学の習慣は
非常に難しくなります。 修正と3
外国語の音を模倣する人間の脳の能力
は時間の経過とともに大幅に低下するため、音声学の重要性を確立しました。
音声認識を開発する次のステップ
は、これがネイティブのよう
なネイティブを開発しようとしている人に提供できる最も重要な情報です。
日本語のアクセントは
、額面通りに音を出すのをやめ
、共同であるように努めます 鋭い音声認識の現在の状態は
、音の背後にある意味だけでなく、オセロットが一人称の発音と高低アクセントパターンを識別するための粒子の努力
として単にあなたを通過させないことを聞いたときの音自体に集中します
それはアトミックです ああ、
中岡、大高
、これらの音声パターンの知識ではなく、これらの音声
パターンを
積極的に識別して模倣しようとする努力が、
実際に
あなたのリスニングとスピーキングの能力を向上させるのです。
これが私が決めた理由です。
個々の高低アクセントパターンのそれぞれを実際に紹介する前に、音声認識と有用な音声慣行をカバーします。
聞き取りが難しいという概念は
、その
単純さにおいて非常に欺瞞的です。
個々の単語やフレーズの高低アクセントパターンこの
アクティブなリスニングマインドセットは、あなたにとってより多くのことを行います
ピッチアクセントパターンに
関連するどの知識よりも話す能力と聞く能力
パート2基本的な
音声の練習基本的な音声の
練習番号1頭の
中で正しく聞こえるので、正しく言っていると思って自分自身を記録
します。 あなたが何かを言っていると思います
、そしてあなたが
実際にそれを言っている方法は完全に
異なっています
この現象は多くの人々が
彼ら自身が彼らの声の知覚を話すのを不快に感じる理由ですそして
スピーチは
あなたがあなた自身を記録しなければならない現実とは非常に異なりますそしてあなたは
これらの記録を分析しなければなりません
私たちがこれを行うときだけ
、私たちは私たちのスピーチで犯した間違いに最終的に気づき始め
、その結果、
それらを修正するために
私たち
が何をする必要があるかを学びます。 自分の録音を聞いて、自分が
言っていることを知っただけで、ちょっとボンパターンで何かを言っていた
古いアッカパターンでは
、間違いを犯していないと確信している場合は、明らかにこの種の間違いを修正することはできません
。
毎日少なくとも30分間、単語ごと
またはフレーズごとのシャドウイングを行うことをお勧めします。
演習を
行ってから、シャドウイング資料の観点からこれらの録音を分析するためにさらに15〜20分を費やし
ます。
これらの資料は
特定の学習レベルに最も適している可能性が高いため、すでに取り組ん
でいるカリキュラムの録音を使用することをお勧めします。
文法の語彙や聴解に元気CDを使用してきました
が、引き続きこれらのCDを使用することをお勧めしますが
、このレッスンの後半で高低アクセントの練習に
使用するために、これらを補足するために使用する必要のある別の資料と練習も紹介します。
レベル固有のシャドウ
レコーディングテイクアウェイポイントレコーディングと
話し言葉の分析は
、ピッチアクセントを改善するための重要なプラクティスの1つです。
発音において、また
アクティブな音声認識
を無意識の習慣に変えることは、この物理的な
練習が実際に
音声ギアを本質的な
音声練習の第2に変えるものです。これ
はやや物議を醸すでしょう。
非母国
語のパートナーは、他の人の前で
外国語を話すために必要なコミュニケーションと自信を育むのに非常に効果
的である可能性があります。
-ネイティブスピーカーネイティブ
これは
音声学を学ぶのに効果的な環境ではないと思います。特に、これ
はすでに日本語のクラスを受講している人々にとって興味深い状況を生み出し
ます。
日本語の学習
環境や クラスメート全員が非常に
やる気がありますあなたの先生
は音声学の重要性が
あなたが教室で聞くほとんどの日本語であると
理解
して
いますか
先生やクラスメートが
音声学に参加するのは大変な
ことのように思えるかもしれませんが、これは
まさに私がやったこと
であり、大学レベルで高低アクセントクラスが開かれることになりました。
それに固執するが
、一方、あなたの
教室が
簡単にしようとしている人々でいっぱいで、あなたの先生
が非ネイティブの文法ナチであるならば、あなたの研究の焦点を音声学に移してみ
てください。 私の
長期的な目標は、
ネイティブのようなアクセントを開発することだったので、私は再び、ほぼ2年間、日本語と文法の研究を個人的に抑制しました。 日本語の勉強を
始めたばかりの人にとっては永遠のよう
です
が、ネイティブのようなアクセントで完全な流暢さを身につけようとし
ているなら、とにかく5年以上勉強するつもりです。
研究のタイムライン
は、全体論的研究モデルから脱却し、
一時的に音声学の本質的な
音声の練習番号3に焦点を当てることが望ましいです。これ
は、必須の音声の
練習番号2
と密接に関連して
います。 俳優が演じる前にセリフを言うので台無しになっている男と友達になって、
彼は
映画を
何度も見たことがありますが、
日本の映画の場合
は、標準的な日常の日本語を使用した映画を選びます。
最後にいくつかの推奨事項を示します。
何度も何
度
も見てください。異なる映画や単一のシリーズの複数のエピソードではなく、単一の映画を使用すること
が重要です。
ナルトのどんちゃん騒ぎの最中に日本語を勉強していると自分に
言い聞かせることと
、同じ作品
を何度も何度も見て実際に話し言葉を勉強していることの大きな違いです。
エピソード2を開始した
瞬間に、同じことを何度も何度も見て、長期記憶に
染み込ませることが重要
です。この演習の目的
は、音声参照のため
に自由に呼び出すことができる日本の映画全体を記憶することです。
日本人の音
を覚えたい
、綴りや漢字ではなく音で言葉を覚えたい
ので、教科書や
漢字アプリの映画は
、これを音声認識と
レベル固有のシャドウレコーディングと組み合わせて、
開発に向けて順調に進んでいます
素材の面でしっかりとした音声基盤オレンジデイズまたはアンジーデイジーと呼ばれるロマンスからの最初の2つのエピソードをお勧め
します 幻想的な
ドラマトウキョウソナタ
は
、日本語の音声学を集中的に勉強していたときに、1日に4回までこれを
行っていました。また、素材に慣れれば、寝ているときに映画を上映
することもできました。 その映画の境界
線を越えて録音を開始
し、今日のエピソードのその映画の要約のネイティブスピーチと比較して、毎日
自分の音声認識記録を作成し
、エピソード5のこのエピソードのすべてである日本語の話し言葉に没頭します。
日本語の高低アクセントの
用語
を紹介し始めます。エピソード6では、日本語の個々の高低
アクセントのパターンを紹介します。音声学の研究
を補足するために使用できるさまざまな無料のサードパーティツール
が少し後に登場
し、全体が紹介されます。
パトレオンとYouTubeの両方
で、引き続きご支援いただきありがとうございます。またお会いし
ましょう
[音楽]